oh my goodness the bbc have now banned
my video response that i did on youtube
responding
to their video that they did about me
this is just ridiculous like i did a
video
it was having loads of comments loads of
views everyone was like samuel thank you
for finally putting the truth out there
on the bbc bad aren't they aren't they
liars people were saying
are the bbc liars and then this video
gets a copyright claim boom
and it suddenly disappears off of
youtube hmm
now bbc if it wasn't you that did this
please tell me who it was and please
tell me why
not only are you making videos about me
and thank you for retracting some of the
comments by the way people like did the
bbc show samuel was a scam
that they retracted that okay they're
like oh sorry it was a junior member of
staff
no one knows this stuff because they
hide it they suppress it
so this video the only reason this could
have had a copyright claim
was because i in my response video
i used a tiny snippet of their video
and then suddenly they get the video
removed but their video
was about me and the little footage i
was using was of me
that they came to my event and they
filmed
me unauthorized put a tiny little
snippet
on the show and did this whole big thing
about it completely nonsense and lies
i then show a little clip of their clip
of me
and to do a whole explaining i talk
about the truth provide evidence and
then boom
it gets a copyright strike because the
bbc owned the copyright that tiny little
snippet
on youtube this is just wrong so i'm
gonna have to re-upload the video
take out that little snippet that they
put in which is my
me anyway it's me then they filmed it
unauthorized and i don't know they'll
probably try and find a way to get it
banned again
again bbc if this wasn't you then tell
me talk to me
let's do a financial freedom challenge
come round my house
and film me let's do some deals let's
just let's find out the truth but they
don't want to do that
they keep hiding just like joe lysett
hiding channel 4 hiding
lord sugar where you at bro where you at
where you at bro
is that him calling me right now i don't
know but anyway watch this
it's probably going to get taken down
again the truth is always being silenced
it's ridiculous
this is getting beyond a joke copyright
claim
from the bbc as far as i'm aware this is
the video i'm gonna re-upload it if you
wanna know the truth watch this video
from beginning to end
before it gets taken down the whole show
in my opinion was quite poorly done
poorly researched
they didn't actually fact check anything
they didn't come to me and say hey can
we talk
they came secretly in my opinion with a
very strong
agenda trying to fit a narrative because
most of my family my friends my students
that saw the show were just absolutely
horrified
at some of the weak journalism in the
show however that's just my opinion
you do you make up your own opinion i'm
gonna go through the points of the show
so the first point is how they portrayed
me
i mean right from the beginning right
from the get-go the very first time you
see me on the bbc show
is with eerie music with me saying i'm
gonna punch you in the throat now that's
not a particularly great first
impression
and what they did was they trolled
through all of my youtube videos
and they found when i said as a joke if
you don't subscribe i'm gonna punch you
in the throat and i was kidding it was
probably a very distasteful thing to say
i shouldn't have said it but in the
context of the whole video
which was called 10 things i wish i'd
known 10 years ago
is a long video maybe about 10 minutes
long they took
about six seconds of that video of me
saying that and put eerie music over it
i would play you the eerie music so you
can see how stupid it was
but unfortunately the bbc had the
copyrights to the music and somehow the
copper writes to me so i can't show that
so the first impression of me right away
is someone saying i'm going to put you
in the throat with eerie music on
not a great first impression i mean what
does that say to you
were they trying to betray me in my
correct light
or are they trying to fit a narrative i
think they were trying to fit a
narrative
they then talked about the fact that
they found out
that i was performing as a magician as
recent as six years ago this is
literally a photograph that i had taken
seven years ago the bbc had put their
logo on it
now he's probably copyrighted and they
made this big thing about this and they
showed secret footage now this footage
that they got was of
me publishing it myself and then taken
out of context
yes as recent as six years ago i did
perform a magic show
my brother alongside with his business
partner craig petty
ran an entertainment agency called
slightly unusual
and i really liked performing and i'm
very open about this i talk about this
in my book
and six years ago yes i did a few shows
for slightly unusual
most of them were for charity and the
ones that weren't often i said
can you please put the money into my
into my charitable works in africa
but that wasn't reported on of course
instead they just said
as recent as six years ago he was doing
a magic show
wow interesting sideline for someone
that claims to be a property millionaire
and i was also doing lots of other
things like climbing kilimanjaro
like playing the trumpet in the warsaw
symphony orchestra like writing a gospel
cd
album but that doesn't contradict the
fact that i was financially free in
property
in fact when you become financially free
what it means is you can do what you
want when you want
and that's everything i'm about and
everything i teach the really
shocking thing in my opinion about the
bbc show
is they didn't even bother to try and
get the information
they just tried to fit their narrative
so they didn't even approach slightly
unusual the entertainment act to say
what was samuel doing
was he employed by you was he working
for free
was he doing it for fun for charity they
didn't ask these questions
and slightly unusual craig petty who i
don't speak to very often
really anymore but when he saw the show
he was so outraged by the fake
journalism
that he actually put together a
statement himself and this is what he
said
craig petty from slightly unusual and
i'm going to attach this in the
description link if you want to see it
to whom it may concern i'm a director of
slightly unusual and previously the
co-owner of magic for hire the two
companies that samuel leeds worked for
as a magician
i have noticed with interest that many
different tv programs and online vlogs
have published stories about samuel many
of these talk about the work he has done
with my companies
but nobody has ever reached out to me
directly to discuss samuel
in 2013 he finished bible college and
his property business had grown by this
point
he even owned houses in my street and i
was extremely impressed with what he'd
achieved
i asked him to continue doing shows
again since he'd finished bible college
but he was in a completely different
place financially
and i knew he didn't need the money i
managed to get him a little involved for
a short while in 2014
but he did this solely for enjoyment and
to help me out he was happy to get
involved in
several charity fundraisers his last
ever show was in 2015 where he told me
he didn't want payment but to donate
money into his charity projects in
africa instead samuel has always been
honest about being a working class guy
and has talked openly about his history
as a magician so it's bizarre the media
would expose this
as some great secret i hope this puts a
stop to the speculation about samuel's
career as a magician
all of the above is true regards craig
petty from slightly unusual limited
so that's when you actually speak to the
people
when you actually speak to the you get
the facts i mean is this newsworthy is
this a big shocking deal
i don't think so but they span it to
make it look like something really fishy
was going on
i mean in the exact same way as they say
things like
many of his customers are unhappy you
watch the bbc show and you have
you have a feeling that my customers and
people that i do business with
aren't happy but that's just not true
over 90 percent of our customers are
happy
in fact to the point where we run our
business off of word of mouth
so how many people did the bbc
interview or have on the show to
represent my customers
bear in mind i've had over 20 000
people do my actual live training
programs so how many of them did they
speak to they had
a grand total of two
people two people so why did they get
only two people that were unhappy if
there's so many unhappy people why
didn't they have 200 people
what percentage is that that's like
0.0001
of people that they chose to speak to
and why did they ignore
every week i have a winner's wednesday
someone becoming financially free or
having their
finances their lives revolutionized as a
result of my training
through property investment every week
what about the 90
of people statistically that are
extremely happy
so in my opinion it's just very
unbalanced bad
reporting when the bbc came to our
free property investors crash course
they came along for free
and they'd been told that there was a
lot of
hard selling that goes on so they came
to the program
ready for hard selling with secret
cameras and they'd seen little clips and
they'd put things together and they'd
heard lots of hearsay
but what was the journalist abby what
was her
experience when she came to the event
well her experience
of what she actually reported on and
what actually happened was this that she
came to the event
and she was told from stage what the
program was was told the price
and was then given a form to fill out a
totally
no obligation form to take or to fill
out or to hand back in
she asked for a form she filled out a
form and on that form
it says can you afford the training
and she said yes and the prices were on
the form
interesting that they never showed that
form she then handed the form in
she then booked an appointment and then
the following
day after sleeping on it
had an appointment with one of our team
and
what happened when she had an
appointment with one of our team she
came in saying she could afford it
and then within a couple of minutes we
said
how would you like to pay for the
training and the journalist was like
freaking out saying they said how would
you like to pay
that's hard selling i'm really sorry but
asking someone
how they'd like to pay after they've
come to your event
they've took a form they've handed it in
they've ticked they can afford it
they've come for an appointment after
sleeping on it
then saying how would you like to pay
that is not hard
selling and you don't even believe in
the techniques
you say that you think deal selling
doesn't really work now of course you
don't actually say
deal selling doesn't work but you make
out that we're exaggerating
you said that you were hard sold to you
when you spoke to one of our training
advisors that explained how deal
selling work again that's not hard
selling
that's telling you how it works and
everything that you were told
is the truth we do sell a lot of deals
i've personally packaged and sold over
200 property deals and the average fee
is two three four
thousand pounds many of my students have
packaged and sold
property deals
[Music]
[Music]
this is very doable maybe if you'd come
to the advanced
training and actually learned about deal
selling you won't be so skeptical and
you'd see how it works but you didn't
you came to the free course you watched
all my youtube videos
with a very strong agenda and a
bias in my opinion if the bbc
really wanted to get a true account
why didn't they at least offer to have
me on the show and interview me
and they won't even do that now they've
done the reporting they've done it and
now they're on to the next story they
won't meet with me to talk about it
they won't respond to this video they're
not interested
and not only do i think the way they
reported was actually immoral
but the thing that really really
saddened me about the bbc
show was the fact that they brought in
the suicide of danny butcher i
at the time said how sad i was that dany
took his life he's one of my students
and the bbc on their news article
got my quote saying danny had took his
life and i was really sad i was
heartbroken
i was praying for the family they got
that quote and then they put a picture
of me next to it
and the picture of me i was smiling on
the picture it was a still shot from a
video of me always laughing
what why why would you
why why would you take a a genuine
sad gutted quote on my facebook which at
the time when i wrote it i had
tears in my eyes and then choose to put
a picture of me next to it
almost laughing what kind of a picture
is that going to create
what no no one knows what was going on
in danny's head when he took his life no
one i don't know what was going on in
his head
he didn't say that to say
or to imply that i am responsible
somehow
for dany's death is not only wrong
but it's just absolutely immoral in my
opinion i think to take
a tragic suicide and then to use that
to try and tell your story to fit your
narrative
why why say in your newspapers even bbc
and on your show why say this man killed
himself
after going on samuel's training course
like one you could have said lots of
things
if you're talking about danny's suicide
you could say he uh man killed himself
after serving in the army man killed
himself just 11 weeks after getting
marriage
man kills himself after after getting a
20 000 pounds worth of debt to lots of
other people but you know
you chose to say after going on samuel's
training course
if i said that danny took his life
because of any of the other examples
because
it's his of his wife or because it was
his parents or because of this or is the
fault of the army because he served in
the army and then this
if i said that or if anyone said that i
thought that even
i think that'd be completely wrong and
shocking and immoral to try and point
the finger like that
and in the exact same way i think people
that are trying to point the finger with
no evidence whatsoever no evidence
even the telegraph said there's no link
the bbc didn't say there's a link
but the way they suggested it and tried
to
make you the viewer point the finger
i think it's absolutely immoral i think
it's wrong
but some people have said but samuel
your training company
the customer service was bad you didn't
look after danny properly
let's let's talk about that when we met
danny for the first time at the crash
course
he was very excited about property he
had five deals in the pipeline
and when he became a student of ours he
knew
that this was a long term game
he knew that his family have even said
that that he knew this was a long time
again this was not going to happen
overnight
and when danny became a student he had
access to me personally
he had my brother russell who's the ceo
of our company at his direct line
he spent more than one hour on the phone
to him on one occasion
and danny at times was really happy and
was thinking the academy was great and
the training was good and property was
great
and then other times he was really
unhappy and he did he did twice
he asked us for a refund the first time
he asked for a refund
we said yes we'll work with you to give
you a partial refund he was already part
way through the training but we offered
him a refund
and then danny said actually i don't
want to refund i'm happy i want to do
property
i i want to continue the training and we
said okay
and then he came back a second time on
the second time when he asked for a
refund which is a couple months later
we again we said we would give him a
refund we the point is
we were working with danny we knew danny
we were working with danny
and his taking his own life
in my opinion had nothing
to do with the fact that he didn't like
our training
and to suggest that and to say that when
there's no evidence
is wrong when i found out that danny had
died
i didn't even think for a second oh
maybe it's because he wasn't happy
with our property training like it
didn't even cross
my mind that that might be the reason
why i've got screenshots and email
threads we were working with danny
danny was viewing properties the week
before i think his dad said even the day
before
he was viewing properties and was upbeat
about how things seem to be going
so i have no idea why he took his life
i've got evidence of everything i'm not
going to publish it because it will be
distasteful but it really needs to stop
the blaming and finger-pointing it's not
cool
an army veteran killed himself after
doing samuel leads his course and it's
reported he didn't make
any money back and just couldn't handle
the debt
this is [ __ ] disgusting samuel leaves
being [ __ ]
jail
[Music]
other people have said that samuel your
company should have known
before you took him on as a student you
should have known that he had mental
health issues
you should have known that he was in the
army had post-traumatic stress disorder
you should have known that he was
already in almost 20 000 pounds worth of
debt
before we even met you you should have
checked that and listen
hindsight is a great thing but i don't
know any company
when you go and get even a very
expensive product if you're buying a car
or if you're buying a holiday or getting
married and paying for an expensive
wedding
i've i've never been asked about my
mental health or
about whether i've got other debts as
far as most
businesses in the uk are concerned if
you're an adult
and you've got the money and you want to
do
it then you're welcome to make up your
own mind to do business that's how
business is typically done
maybe that's not right maybe there
should be more stricter checks
in place i don't know maybe maybe that
would be better but what i can say is
what our company did
in how we accepted danny on to do our
training is no different from any
training company in the uk whether that
be property training different training
or anything else
in what world if a university student
takes their life
to people say oh wait it's the
university you know they had student
debt they
it's it's unthinkable and some will say
but your company
preys on the vulnerable it preys on
disadvantaged people that haven't got
money
again this is completely
wrong no facts no evidence
you can look at the demographic of our
students yes we do take people from all
walks of life
but to prey on the vulnerable to prey on
people that haven't got money and are
poor
doesn't make any business or financial
or commercial sense whatsoever
it doesn't make any sense and we rely
on our students succeeding we rely on
that
because if they succeed our business
works off of word of mouth
and that's why over 90 of our customers
are happy
that's why we have success students on
our channel all the time
and that's what grows our company should
there be more regulation
in the wealth creation or training space
probably yes
i'd be the biggest ambassador for
regulation
and we self-regulate ourselves and are
pushing that more and more which i'll be
talking about on future videos
i'm not asking you watching this video
to show any support in any way you don't
have to comment you don't have to give
your opinions and say
samuel we support you i'm not asking for
that what i'm asking for
is for people to stop placing the blame
over a suicide with no evidence and
making
things up to try and tear me and my
company down
needs to stop
my response to the bbc that put the
documentary together
if you turned over all the stones and
there's nothing unturned
why did you have nothing to talk about
except
try and be suggestive about a tragic
suicide
20 000 students most of them very happy
successful
wealthy why did you choose two
for your case study like if you were
doing a dissertation
at university you would have failed
you'd be getting an
f why did you want to choose two and why
did you pick two people that were
unhappy
one of those people by the way i'm going
to be doing a video about at a later
date because it's an interesting story
why did you choose to as the very first
image
have me saying i'm going to punch you in
the throat and put eerie music over it
let me ask you a question bbc did you be
honest
did you come with an agenda
were you really coming to seek truth
were you really coming to give a
balanced
report or did you come with an agenda
tell me the truth
and if you didn't come with an agenda if
you really came to seek the truth
and if you re your conclusion was that
deal selling doesn't really work and i
oversell it then if you're really
interested
why don't you spend a week with me doing
a financial freedom challenge
bbc i'm here send someone from your team
bring your camera crew do a financial
freedom challenge with me
and watch me make ten thousand pounds
from scratch
and you you can choose the charity that
ten thousand pounds goes to
i challenge you if you're really seeking
the truth
and for anyone watching this video what
i'll say is when you hear the media in
the news or people
make up your own mind
even the bbc they didn't do any of my
paid for training
they came with an agenda they spoke to
two people
that's all i can say guys i didn't want
to have to do this video i know it's
been a little bit morbid
however i appreciate your support more
videos coming soon
thank you for watching i'll see you next
time so that's the sad story of the bbc
it's been painful but i'm going to keep
speaking truth and there was a time when
i didn't defend myself i just thought
i'll let people see my results but when
you don't put the facts out there people
make stuff up so
i want to say massive thank you to
people that have stood with me through
all the nonsense that went on in the bbc
and different media channels thank you
to the people
because i see people commenting all over
with false allegations and then i see
some of
some some truth speakers jumping on and
responding and putting people right so
thank you for that
i would do it if there was ten of me i
just spent my whole time responding to
people
you know putting the truth out there so
thank you for those guys that have done
that and have just
seen things clearly made up your own
mind i'm going to keep doing videos i'm
going to keep inspiring keep educating
and your success is my oxygen i'll see
you real soon
thanks for the support